[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show where
we help people win in their life
specifically their money in their work
and in their relationships the phone
number to jump in is
8255 225 I'm Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality and I'm joined by Ramsey
personality and my good friend Jade
warshaw she's our money Guru on today's
show I'll help you out in areas of work
and income uh getting that income up and
we team up together to take your
questions 888 825 5225 you ready to go
I'm ready to do it K ready to go
Columbus Ohio is where we start Nick is
there Nick how can we help hey Ken hey
Jade how are you guys doing today we're
having a blast what's
up so uh my wife and I are in a bit of a
pickle uh some background real quick is
uh we just got married a few months ago
uh we had a really expensive last year
with weddings and our wedding and all
that uh we got through it all uh we
combined our finances and uh we started
tackling a big mountain of student loans
and uh various smaller loans together
here the last few
months um so we're in the middle of baby
step 2 and uh we recently got invited
and actually uh my wife was asked to be
in the wedding we got invited to a
wedding out of the country o where oh uh
it's in Italy oh I love that always oh
my goodness so and she's supposed to be
part of the bridal party too which is
even more expensive because you got the
dresses and the activities and the latia
um how much dead do you guys have uh we
are we have about 97,000 left okay
97,000 left and um who who is this
person to you whose wedding is this uh
it's one of her best friends um not
family or anything but like recent best
friends or best friends from high school
or from college like is this person in
her daily life dayto day yeah uh I would
say I mean they've been best friends for
the last four or five years I wouldn't
stay since they grew up together like
they didn't grow up together is she the
maid of honor
no okay so she's not the made of monor
which means she ain't the best friend
unless the girl has a sister it does
matter in this it does matter okay right
I um I'm going to shoot you straight
here because I don't think that you guys
can afford a trip to
Italy and I don't think that you can
afford all of the things that goes along
with being a bridesmaid because in 2023
these bridesmaid prices have gone
through the roof yeah what are we
talking about do we have a price tag I'm
curious ni it's it's the parties it's
everything so what what do you think
it's going to cost so um the whole thing
is about four days I believe that's the
minim the minimum like stay and that's
not even including travel I priced out
to about 6,000 that's if we just did the
four days and that's for the two of
you I mean yeah flights I can't find
anything
under uh like four grand for two flights
right and then there's tuxedo dresses is
that is that everything
included yeah the the next question I
have is do you have
$6,000 um we don't um we did save a
little bit of our um we got some money
from the wedding and we put most of it
towards our debt
um and we did save about 3,000 of it in
case we decided to go to Italy so what's
the pickle because that implies to me
that you maybe you guys aren't on the
same page is that
true yeah I mean she's all in Ono it's
her friend kind of I'm on the we can't
afford it side but I don't want to come
between let me ask you this cuz if it
were me if I were you um and and the and
the script was flipped and it was my
husband who wanted to go for his friends
I would say what would you think about
us throwing a really nice bridal shower
or in this case Grooms party for your
friend here stayside and we can do that
and that way we're finding a way to
participate doing something nice but we
can also keep it within a much smaller
scope all right come on now and not bust
I that's Jade the financial expert and
the very disciplined person who changed
her life you're legit but come on I want
I want Jade the woman on this okay so
like if he says that to his wife I think
she goes sorry pal that's not a viable
option I have a find a way to meet in I
got one okay hit him Ken he doesn't go
he says babe this is your dear friend I
know that they would pain you not to go
it's a big deal but babe we are in fin
,000 he can go make
$3,000 when is the when is the trip in
June okay between now no I'm okay if you
don't like this I don't know how I feel
I'm still marinating good because I am
trying to help this man in his marriage
and and and I am asking you as a woman
get real If This Were you and Sam and
this was your really good friend and you
were in come on now all right Ken he has
no option but to work his butt off he
can sell stuff make some money come up
with and I don't think it's three grand
if she goes I think can the and and Nick
we're we're arguing this for you he's
got to say something hold on go ahead if
it's any consolation we're putting about
thousand a month towards our debt
exactly this is a cash flow exactly and
and for me I'm like if you can just go
out and earn $3,000 for a wedding I'm
like I all I see is your debt going from
97 down to 94 that's what I see I'm like
look with almost $100,000 of debt how
long have you guys been working the the
baby step to how long have you been in
it it's been like two and a half months
you you're just getting started I all I
see is his wife resenting him for years
to come when she's looking at Instagram
and seeing the wedding pictures she's
not she's not what get her on the phone
I'm telling you I'm right this she she's
going to be she she's going to be mad
for a minute but here's the thing can I
don't even talk about my wedding on a
weekly basis a monthly basis or a yearly
basis it's not even her day she's going
to get over it you're the exception oh
she's going to get over at all K Coleman
you looked at your wedding album man I'm
a dude but this is a woman weddings to
women is a whole different I'm a woman
too I just gave you the perspective I
just don't think you're keeping it real
well okay the man is calling us with a
money and relationship question and I am
trying to help him with both look Nick
what are you leaning towards after you
heard Ken and I chop it chop it up what
do you think I it's just I'm between
pausing the debt and saving up some
money and just you know going the
minimum that we need to be there um we
also postponed our honeymoon we didn't
do a honeymoon
because honestly we underestimated how
expensive Italy was going to be that was
supposed to be and see that's the thing
you didn't do your own honeymoon to do
okay do on the phone talk I want you to
understand you're grown so you're going
to walk away and do what you want and
whatever makes you sleep at night
however what I do want to tell you is
you're just getting started and the
choices that you make now are setting
the tone for your whole baby step two
Journey so the moment that you start
saying this is the exception or that's
the exception you're you're you're
creating a rule you're creating a rule
with this decision I agree with you I'm
trying to help him out like I I cuz I
got the Feeling we running out of time
with him but I have the feeling his wife
is really like I'm going she wants to go
everybody wants to go to Italy and
everybody wants to be in their friend's
wedding I'm not saying that that's not
the case no dude in the world any dude's
like yeah sorry pal I can't afford this
but women is a different deal so I want
to see you sit down and have a
candlelight dinner conversation with
Mama and see where she's really at and
then I if you really have to split the
difference my option is a viable option
and not stop paying the debt I don't
want him to slow down say he's going to
cash flow on top of paying the debt off
I know I wish I was as hardcore as you
I'm not this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but some something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
apply
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
we're thrilled you're with us we're here
to help you with your money and your
work questions today I'm Ken Coleman
Jade warshaw joins me our question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services when you need
to make repair schedule routine
maintenance or get local help for Home
Improvement projects go to neighborly
docomo find and schedule reliable home
service providers in your area all right
today's question comes from Dalton in
Kentucky my wife and I have been stupid
over the last year we moved across the
country for a job and immediately
purchased a home while still having
student loans after finding the reality
of our new job was not accurately
displayed in the interview process my
wife and I made the move back to our
home state both of us having higher
paying jobs than before wow however we
were financially wrecked from letting
the dream become a nightmare and have to
receive financial help from my parents
we have just said no to a car loan for
four Let's see we have just said no to a
car loan for
$445,000 for a $455,000 vehicle and feel
empowered again to start the baby steps
that that's good my question is how do
we start and find the motivation after
backsliding for the last year now this
is an interesting question
because he says they backslid but he
doesn't really explain exactly what all
they did cuz it sounds like you you
turned down the car loan which was great
it sounds like the big mistake here was
you moved for a job you bought a home
and then you had to kind of come back I
don't know what tail between your legs
and go back to your home state now
unless you took a major hit when you
moved from the home I'm not seeing where
you made a bunch of mistakes cuz it says
look we both went back to our home state
and we have higher paying jobs than
before so I'm struggling to see Ken what
they look if you say you backslid for a
year then I believe you that you
backslid for a year I don't know exactly
what that looks like but what it sounds
like is you understand the baby steps
and you understand the Ramsay principles
and you you know what you've
done and so this is really just your
wakeup call to go okay like we made a m
mistake it's not about what I did it's
about what I did next and now you're
back in Kentucky and so now it's time to
get after it again yeah you know it's
funny when somebody ask how can you find
the motivation we get those questions a
lot in different aspects of the work we
do here at ramsy and the root word of of
motivation is motive and most of the
time we use the word motive it's in a
legal context right and so most of us uh
we hear the word motive in a some type
of a legal drama whether it's a
television show or a movie and so what
do they trying to do the pro the
prosecutor is trying to prove to the
jury that the defendant had a motive to
do whatever it is they've been charged
with so they're going what's the motive
they had motive to act this way so when
we look at it that way I'm breaking it
down a little nerdy word exercise to
then
say well motivation is just the act of
moving forward on something that you
want to happen there's so motive is
about emotion and so if I want to be
free of debt free of these mistakes free
of whatever he's talking about free of
Shackled to a credit card or a carpet
whatever it is I can't live the life I
want meaning I'm too stressed out
because of debt or I can't do some of
the things I want to do because I don't
have any money okay so focus on that
feeling that's very good that
emotion and I'm really nerding out right
now come on you're a thespian Ken I'm
I'm ready and again we got the word
emote mhm motive emote I'm just saying
get you want to get motivated focus on
that emotion that is nagging at you
driving you crazy that is not allowing
you the emotion is a result of I'm not
where I want to be in my life so whether
it's losing weight getting a better gig
a job getting out of debt uh getting out
of a bad abusive relationship what
motivates someone to act is the feeling
yeah you change the the way you you feel
you'll change the way you act and so
I've got to get into that negative
feeling to then pursue what I need to do
to get the positive feeling I'm not
trying to get all psychology on it but
that's that's how we get motivated
what's your motive I like that Ken you
do have to think about your motive and
you know my two cents to add to that is
I think that people look at motivation
often as a as a they they need that in
order to start right and I'm like listen
motivation is really a byproduct of
having started you get that reward of
ooh I did it you know you get that hit
of what dopamine or whatever and you're
feeling good about yourself and then you
go hey this really works and then you
have motivation and action which is like
okay I want to keep going with this and
so if you're sitting around you you can
go Ken's route which some people are
able to just up and motivate themselves
and get going they feel that emotion
it's enough to drive them and then
there's other people who's like listen
you need to start regard L of how you
feel you just need to up and start and
take it one day at a time don't look at
the whole that gum Journey look at one
foot in front of the other and then
tomorrow is a new set of uh choices that
you get to make but if you're sitting
around waiting for lightning to strike
you and for you know the current to go
through your body and then you got the
spirit and you move that may not happen
for you uh motivation is a product of
after you start you feel it and and and
you want to keep going so all right good
question though thank you for the
question all right let's get to the
phones we go to the Big Apple Jason is
on the line there Jason how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
um quick question I live in New York
City with my wife I'm 37 years old we
have a kid we've got one more on the way
within the next couple weeks wow and
we're thinking about uh we're we're
thinking about moving to the suburbs um
we have no debt we're in a pretty good
financial situation and I'm thinking
about taking out a small mortgage which
goes against everything I have ever
learned in life in terms of get into
debt and it scares me to death um you
know we have our budget it you know we
can afford it but again it's it's money
that I'm going to be paying to a
mortgage that I can be saving uh and use
in the future so my question is you know
if I can afford something how do I know
if it's decision and and and am I making
a mistake um by by taking out a mortgage
right now well listen I let me be the
first to say we are a no debt you know
that's our philosophy no debt but the
only debt that we're never going to you
know get mad at you for taking out is a
home mortgage when you do it the right
way and within reason um so if you you
know if it's your principle in life that
you just like Dave Ramsey does not
borrow money not even for a home
purchase okay so if you want to go to
that level and if you've decided hey I'm
Jason and that's my standard I'm not
going to take that away from you in this
moment but I would like to introduce you
to the idea if you're open to it that
look taking out a small amount for a a
mortgage is not a bad thing if you would
like to be open to that how much are you
talking about taking out it would be a
pretty small mortgage probably between
four and 500,000 okay and um what would
be the cost like are you putting
anything with that
money we'd be putting a significant
amount of money down and and I guess I
forgot to say we we our apartment in the
city we we we've been saving up for a
very long time we bought our apartment
all cash wow and I'd be using all that
that Equity to buy a house with a
mortgage on top beautiful house with
with the equity that we have absolutely
so we don't we don't need it and again I
would just be mad at myself 20 years
down the line if you know I said why did
I take morage when I could have afforded
Jason give me two numbers what's the
purchase price of the house you're
talking about and what's your combined
income yeah so our purchase price is 2
million and our combined income is about
550,000 all right that's what Jade
needed to on that yeah so I mean you're
paying 1.5 million in cash which is
amazing
yeah incredible and then you've got a
really strong income I like this to
where look chopping down a mortgage of 4
to 500,000 when you've got a $550,000
mortgage especially since you are now
moving out of the city so your cost
living is going down um I Jade warshaw
would 100% do that and I would sleep
like a baby yeah because of your income
and the size of the down payment do you
understand what we're saying Jason so
this is not a crazy
move okay
it just it's it scares me I've never
been in debt in my entire life so it it
it scares me to
death don't do it most people don't put
down 3/4 of the amount of the loan in
cash you're you're a unicorn just by
those numbers alone with your income and
the amount you put down but listen if
you don't feel right about it don't do
it I mean if you don't feel good about
it a $1.5 million house is amazing so
why ask him how much longer would it
take to save up to pay cash for
something like that those houses are
still going to be that's right that's
good Ken you got options you got options
Jason I I I think you got to trust your
feelings uh talk it out with the wife
make sure on the same page on all that
but you financially for taking out a
mortgage you guys you you easily meet
our criteria is what we're telling you
so thanks for the call Jason all right
don't move she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken
Coleman you're listening to the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win with your money in your
work and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me and we are
here for you this hour the phone number
to jump in is 888 825 5225 that's 8825
5225 let's go to Tampa Florida Connor
joins us Connor how can we help hey guys
how you doing great what's going on
on yeah so I'm interested in pursuing a
graduate degree and I am 24 single no
dependent I'm on I've completed baby
step three and my question is paying for
that graduate degree without going into
student RS so getting some guidance on
doing that how much is it going to
cost uh master's program is looking
about
$45,000 and a PhD is looking at Double
that are you planning to pursue both or
just cons considering
both I'm I'm I'm going through the
process of figuring out what program is
best for me because I really want to be
able to work what do you want to
do I want to be a professor in
international relations all right and
does that require a
PhD I become a professor yes so this is
the only way for you to teach at the
level you want to teach you have to have
a
PhD would start off with getting a
master's or going for into a 4-year PhD
program so yes that is the route which
is most efficient could you jump
straight to the PHD in other words I
don't know this world the higher ed
world like you do do I need the Masters
if I can go straight to a
PhD it wouldn't necessarily you would
need them need the Masters but I'm
trying to work full-time while also
paying for this program part-time so the
programs I've been finding out there is
it' be it looks like it'd be easier to
get the master's program first and then
jump into a PhD Program full time I get
that but my point is does the Masters
help you make more money in the meantime
is that what why you think you need the
Masters uh it I'm a teacher so it would
give me a little bit of a bump but it
would not give me a toward finishing
that PhD that I wouldn't do it you're
asking I wouldn't do it it's not giving
me enough bump and you know what it's
doing it's
delaying uh the the the the the action
needed to get into the PHD program and
if I'm going to cash flow it meaning can
I do it as I go or do I need to press
pause and just save up the money for the
PHD program which you said is how much
again it's you looking anywhere from
like 90 to 120 depending on which school
you go to I mean if it were me I would
skip the Masters i' i' I'd start busting
it working as much as I could this is a
long-term play and I'd save up the money
and so to me the Masters is effort that
doesn't Roi I could be using that time
to work extra to tutor to uh take a
different job get out of the education
space and get a higher paying job I've
got to come up with the way to cash flow
this PhD because the PHD in this case is
the only way in the arena so why spend
the time effort and money on something
that isn't
necessary understood
understood unless I'm missing something
like I don't want to I'm not trying to
put you in a corner I'm just going to
walk through this
logically so that I'm putting all my
effort into getting that PhD that's the
ticket no I understand I understand
where you're coming from Jade any
thoughts on that how long does it I have
two thoughts a how long does it take to
get the
PHD uh full-time you're looking at four
to five years but did you say you're
doing part-time
well my idea was to keep working my
current job and to pursue a master's
program then jump into the uh PhD
program because the master's program I
can work and pay off as I go with the
amount of current cash I have right but
if you go if you take Ken's route and
you go straight to the PHD are you doing
that full-time or are you having to do
like a yes okay yeah that would be
fulltime and the question is can you
afford what is it $22,000 a year for the
next four years can you afford that
um currently no currently no so then my
question for you is what's the plan
because we can't enter into this without
a plan to being able to pay for it or
else you will do what so many other
people do in default to student loans
thinking that's your only option the
plan is
patience got to wait a little bit got to
wait you got to work and you got to you
got to work and that means you got to
wait and if you wait it's worth the wait
I can tell you because you're going to
come out of this see here's the deal
let's can I play another Little Numbers
Game with you Connor you willing to do
this sure all right let's say you do
what most people do and you take out a
loan for this so you're going to be how
much in debt 90 to 120 he's gonna
cash I said about 40 to 50 Grand in
student loans would probably be taken
out right okay so 40 to 50 and so how
much are you going to make what's a
reasonable salary you're going to make
if you get this professor job right out
of being a PhD what's the salary going
to be 80 grand so 80 grand starting out
starting now I want you to fast forward
I want you to fast forward to this
reality because I believe you'll get
there and I know you can get the loan so
now you're going to be making 80 this
thing you've been working for years for
going full-time all the time to put in
there and then you're making 80 and you
owe half of your gross pay
more you see what I'm
saying I do you got to fast forward
nobody ever fasts forward
into this discussion because everybody
goes you're going to get a PhD and
you're going to be Dr Connor so and so
and you're going to have this awesome
international relations job at this
great campus but you're going to be
broke and you're going to be miserable
I'm asking you to wait I'd rather deal
with the emotion of patience than the
emotion of misery there there's they're
very different emotions and let me add
one to that Ken um you're working hard
right now and you're going to be working
very very hard to get this PhD let's
just let's pretend that you go through
with your way where you take out the 40
to 50,000 in student loan debt you work
your way through this program work fast
forwarding like Ken said here's the way
you're going to feel relief I finally
got this PhD I finally got through the
last thing you're going to want to do is
buckle down and live on beans and rice
rice and beans to pay off $50,000 of
debt and you're what so many people do
is go I've worked hard I'm entitled I
should be able to just come home kick my
feet up enjoy my paycheck you're not
going I'm just telling you you're not
going to want to pay off this debt and
that's when people get into trouble
because it starts ballooning and it's
like all right I'll get to it later I'll
get to it later and one thing with
student loans if you try to get to it
later it'll get to you let's see uh
dream for us a little bit what what
would be an ideal job after getting the
PHD give me a give me a university that
you're give me a city a university talk
me through that
uh either I'm from Florida so either UCF
or be a top tier you know ivy league
institution yeah okay so imagine being
in any of those places and the positive
side of this is you waited and now
you're making 80,000 and you're
comfortable you're comfortable you can
actually enjoy your life you don't you
don't come home after a full day of
teaching and stressing out about the
bills that's what I'm asking you to wait
for MH I'm I'm asking you to wait for
the gig but the gig without
pressure that's worth waiting for in my
it's my take Connor but listen Jad and I
are the rare people that going to tell
you this everybody else is going to go
ah it's fine it's the price of admission
and that's just false it's it's it's
like half truth yeah it's the price of
admission you got to pay the 90 to 120 I
don't question that but you don't have
to loan it that's right that's right Ken
yeah we're going to tell you the hard
truth we're going going to look not just
at right now but like you said Kenneth
at the future and that's that's where
the decision is made right there so
Connor how's your stomach right
now no I'm just taking in your guys'
advice indigestion little stress you
feeling some peace about this what are
you thinking I've I've made no decisions
yet so I'm really just trying to figure
out you know have your guys advice I
everybody else well here's the deal we
are in the minority my friend so
at the end of the day this is up to you
but I'm asking you to press fast forward
and play that out and really sit with
those emotions most people don't do that
they deal with it when it comes and then
they're like golly this sucks look when
I was in elementary school there was a
poster on the wall that said in a world
of followers dare to be a
leader and when you go to school and pay
cash for it you are leading my friend
Connor I think Jade just double dog
dared you as we used to say at
elementary school
we'll see what he does will he be one of
the masses or will he be one of the few
leaders who does it differently that's
the question we'll talk about it on the
break don't move we'll be right back
this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then here there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramy show thrilled
that you are with us I'm Ken Coleman
Jade warshaw joins me the phone number
to jump in Isle
88255 225 Jade is our resident money
expert and I'm the work expert so those
two issues go together so hey if you're
feeling like 2024 is your year you feel
like I want to make a change I want to
make some more money but I'm in the baby
steps Ken how do I do that I love those
kind of questions or just anything
related to your work we'll take those
wait uh Jade not Wade Jade will Wade in
is where I was going on those as well
and so we're always thrilled to take
your questions whatever you want to talk
about America we're here for you
8825 5225 let's go to Brandon now in
Buffalo New York Brandon how can we
help hey guys thanks for having me on
how's it going we are having a blast
what's happening with you so I'm
24 I have
$260,000 in student debt no where's my
Tums I gotta look for them wow where'
you go where'd you go to school and
what'd you go to school for so uh
yesterday I took my my last Law School
exam I went to Syracuse Unity University
College of Law take the bar in February
nice okay okay so what kind of law you
going to
practice uh personal injury is the job I
accepted after I passed the bar and the
reason I'm asking is I'm gonna get out
of Jade's way but I am curious what do
you think your first year since you
accepted the job I'm guessing they
talked about potential money I'm just
curious what you think you could make in
those first 12
months yeah so I already signed the
contract the base salary is 80,000 and
then it's they are bonus offers but I I
don't know what that entails so
somewhere between 80 and 90 I would
imagine okay okay so what's your
question I have two questions one is
paying is putting myself in that much
that for a law degree worth it given my
starting
salary should have could have would have
my guy yeah I know I know hindsight's
2020 hindsight's 2020 so we're here now
yeah we'll just accept where we're at
and we'll move on from here so let's
make it worth it
right my answer is it better be okay
that's what I'm saying um yeah we're
going to make it worth it so what was
the second part of your
question how to tackle this debt so 60
of it is private student loans from
undergrad and 200 of it is Federal loans
for law school okay so should I tackle
that
60,000 private higher interest rate
loans first and pay very little on the
200,000 or should I kind of paid all
equal at the same time well my first
question would be to you is this your
only debt period like do you have any
other debt besides student loans no no
credit card no personal loans my car is
paid I rent no other debt and then my
next question to you would be do you
have any money laying around for savings
do you have any money in stocks any
other money that you could get to that's
not retirement saving
nothing significant well what do you
have like $55,000 in my bank account
okay I'm glad you told me about that
okay so I'll since you asked I'm going
to walk through our series of baby steps
and this is exactly what I would do if I
were in your shoes and by the way I was
in your shoes my husband and I paid off
280,000 of student loans okay and this
is what we did we set $1,000 aside of
our money we didn't have much but we set
$1,000 aside and we said this is our you
know rainy day fund this is our starter
emergency fund it's not much but if
something goes down it's there in the
pocket waiting for us okay then we took
any money above all of that and we
decided we're going to throw that at our
debt snowball and that's baby step two
is you pay off all of your debt except
the mortgage using the debt snowball
method now here's how that works and I
want to be specific with student loans
because it can get a little hairy with
student loans a lot of times you'll see
okay I've got one big loan it's $330,000
and there's one payment but if you
really look closer it's divided maybe
into four or five or six or seven loans
where all of that that one payment that
you make it's getting dispersed across
those six or seven loans so what I want
you to do is log in and really make sure
you're looking at the loan in full
because what you're going to end up
doing is listing these loans in order
from smallest to
largest and what's important about
knowing that is let's say okay so you
said you've got a 60 ,000 personal loan
right now is that just one payment that
you're responsible for one monthly
payment the $60,000 I'm sorry is in a
private just it was a private student
loan right um that I I'm not paying on
that yet I still have a few months
because I'm just finishing law school
but I think it will be just one payment
it'll be probably one payment but if you
look closer it's probably divided over
semester that you took it out so when
you do that that would be technically
that $60,000 loan is going to be the
first one in your debt snowball okay but
with the debt snowball you make minimum
payments on everything but you put all
the extra money on the smallest debt so
on that $60,000 you're going to need to
look and go okay it's divided into four
little ones what's the smallest one and
you're going to have to call in and say
hey I already made my payment for the
month but here's $800 extra dollars and
I want it to go to this specific debt
because if you don't tell them that
they're going to spread it across all
those little ones and you're not going
to make Headway does that that make
sense yes it does okay so you got to do
it like that and then you're going to
see those 3,000 gone you're 4,000 gone
and you're going to knock them out
really fast so that's thing one the
second thing I want you to consider
doing is while you're paying off these
student loans this is the only only only
time that I would suggest doing some
sort of a IDR with the Federal loans so
that you can get them to the smallest
possible balance so that you can have
more money freed up to throw at your
smallest debt does that make sense
okay Yep this is not a long-term play
this is not you kicking the can down the
road this is you going hey uh federal
government I want to make these loans as
low as it's possible because I have to
make p minimum payments on everything I
have more money freed up to put on my
smallest debt in this case it's that
private student loan and then that's how
you do it you work through you pay off
the smallest one then you take all that
money you throw it at the next smallest
St and that's how the snowball goes and
it's going to blow your mind how much
progress you're going to make on this
especially with your salary are you a
single
guy I am not I am not I I I have a
girlfriend who we're we're moving
planning on getting engaged soon she is
in medical school and also
have okay so she's got the medical debt
um well first of all you are single
until you until you get married you're
single so don't combine don't combine
finances either so so when is the what
do you think the marriage date is going
to be what it really I mean just give us
an idea we we chat about it a lot now
we're thinking a couple years from now
oh boy okay so while you're
separate you you're working your
snowball she's working her snowball and
you're you guys are pinky swearing that
you are going ham on your you know
respective debts right yeah for the
older people in the audience I need an
interpretation on what she meant by that
a couple weeks ago that means getting
after it getting getting after it now
what's her med school debt going to be
or is it at this
point uh so it will be total about 200
go oh
oh what did you used to watch Sanford
and Son and he go I'm coming to meet you
I
probably I need my own sound effect I'll
just make it myself I'm just going to
like grab my chest that's a lot man it's
a lot but you guys can do it you can do
it what's her uh salary going to be
coming out do you
know she's hoping she's hoping around
200 okay that's better that's good okay
okay I got advice for you my friend you
need a police scanner invest in a police
scanner and you are at every every
accident there is you need to get a fat
bonus is there any Commission on you
bringing in new
business there is I'm serious I'm not
joking she thinks I'm joking you told
this man to chase the ambulance wow
that's there's a re listen he's in
personal injury you can't afford
commercials you're the low man on the
totem pole I would literally figure out
what now police scanner may be
ridiculous but kind of makes sense to me
I'd be showing up at every scene of an
accident making sure everybody's okay
and right for before they go home going
hi my name's Brandon your next stiff
that would be like I I mean dude I got
to get out of debt yeah I hear you I I
must say for now at least the job I just
accepted I represent the other side so I
represent the defendant being sued by
these people okay but I can I still I
can still get a commission on bringing
in new clients no you know what I'd show
up at the same scene of the accident and
instead of the person that's got the
stiff neck you're going to the other guy
who's like thinks his life is over going
listen I'm your guy like he stopped
short didn't he I'm going to fight
for I'm just saying you know wow it's
good Ken yeah he needs to make extra
money you're right I mean I would be
everywhere I would sleep with one eye
open police scanner and one ear I mean
man I don't know I get after it hey good
hour Jade warshaw hey don't move we're
coming back this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you America win in your
life specifically your money your work
and your relationships all three of
those are tied so closely together
you're not winning in one and you're
probably losing in a few if not all so
we want to help you I'm Ken col Jade
warshaw joins me she's our money expert
I am your expert in work today so we'll
take any and all of those questions 8825
5225 is the number 8825 5225 we start
this hour with Jason in Salt Lake City
Utah Jason how can we
help hey Ken um my question is mostly
for you it's what you would do in my
shoes um I currently am renting and I
can afford a house and or condo uh in in
cash not and or or a condo in cash but I
uh am enjoying my rent where I live I
love the place I live and I don't
necessarily want to buy a house or condo
yet and I'm wondering what you would do
if you were in my shoes I would do
exactly what you're doing uh with the
evidence you've given me so far if if if
you enjoy where you're living and
financially you sound like you're in
really good shape how much cash do you
have I have about 550 are you
single I am yeah how
old uh 27 and what do you love so much
about renting this particular place like
give me more on that yeah I got a great
View and uh it's nice that I don't
really have to worry about anything um
you know it's all after after I pay my
rent no maintenance or anything like
that and I'm concerned though you know I
don't obviously I want to get married
have his and whatever but I know once if
and when I buy a house that may change
when I'm married so I was thinking the
condo route but then you get the H fees
and and all of that and I'm no you don't
want a condo well when you get the wife
of the kiddos the condos that's it's not
the ideal situation especially where you
are how much do you make and how much
are you saving and then how much are you
investing give me the answer to those
three
questions yes so I make 120 um I max out
all my other uh my 401k and HSA and all
those uh I think I can put in
30% and then I uh and then I invest the
rest into my brokerage account so the
550 that you have is that in the
brokerage or is that across everything
that yeah that's that's in the brokerage
yeah how did you save that up so fast
how long did it take
you yeah so some of that is from my
parents um and then i' I've I would say
hit the DNA lottery so i' I've
definitely you know they paid for my
school and okay I've definitely worked
hard as well but I haven't had any debt
or anything like that you know because
he's investing so much I mean he's solid
I yeah I listen don't feel the itch I
would not feel the itch if I were you to
buy at this stage of your life you're
going to buy and I think that when your
family situation changes and all that
I'd keep stacking cash because you're
going to be able to pay for whatever you
want cash contrary to that Ken well of
course you do I may feel a little if I
Say ying you you say Yang but I I'm fine
with that I just don't know why he has
he likes where he lives he likes the
view he's in great financial shape he's
not married yet why should he buy a
house well I I don't think you should
feel rushed don't get me wrong I don't
think you should feel rushed but my
questions would be okay like how long
have you been renting for the last seven
years for the last how long have you
been renting and living on your own yeah
on my own about four I guess four or
five years and I've been renting yeah
but I had roommates this is the first
almost coming up on a year where I've
been on my own and I have not had reate
okay so you've rented for five six years
what's your
rent I'm sorry how much do you pay in
rent uh 1400 all right I'm gonna give it
back to Jade Jade disagrees with me here
I want to hear this well then my next
question so I'm just I'm just Gathering
more facts before I really form my next
question to you is is there a
significant is there a lovely lady in
the picture is all I'm
asking there is not no I am single and
so look looking so if you know anyone
listen single ladies in Salt Lake
there's your uh invitation well here's
where M my mind goes to I don't want you
waiting to buy a home because I might
meet a lady and we might get married and
that's probable you probably will but
you don't know when that's going to
happen um so I don't want that to be the
reason that you wait to get into home
ownership and I also don't want the
ownership to be because of oh these
rates they're so high I'm just going to
wait till rates to go down um I just
want to make sure that those aren't the
driving factors are they the driving
factors not necessarily no but like like
Jade saying at some point I need to buy
you know it's like you don't want to run
forever I don't I agree but that's not
the scenario I I'm going to tell you I
respectfully disagree with you he's
single he's got a great view he's single
he's got a view but I I just am thinking
about overtime here's what I know about
you Jason you are a great saver you're
great at getting after task and my
thought is like listen you buy a house
you you own it in cash you have the
ability to build wealth so quickly he's
going to have this Equity working for
him he's going to pick a place that he
loves he's going to pay for it in cash
it's going to build up he's going to
save more money he's the kind of guy
that's going to have a giant real estate
portfolio but I'm regardless whether you
start in three and don't get me wrong
I'm not saying he has to be rushed and
buy a house tomorrow but I'm saying
listen If I Were Us the next two years
I'd be thinking about owning a home is
all I'm saying okay then all right if
I'm going to meet you in the middle on
this one I'd say it better be a smaller
one so that we just call it a real
investment not the home cuz we don't
know what his situation is going to be
when he gets a woman she doesn't like
his house well no home is the home
anybody who thinks this is the one I'm
going to live here forever no you're not
what do you recommend I think listen a
$300,000 house I would spend his money
550 he's in Salt Lake City Ken I
wouldn't spend all 550 on it Jason
what's it what's it cost to get what you
need in Salt Lake City in the area that
you
like uh to get a nicer home I would say
around 550 but I I could get one around
three three to 400 as well what's a
nicer home is how many
bedrooms oh I would I would say like a
minimum a three bed two bath home yeah
you're a single guy but my point is
exactly that's why I don't need that
that's why you don't need that and I'm
not saying that he has to buy a house
for his future family I'm not saying
that at all to buy a $550,000 house cash
as an investment property no I'm saying
I just want him to buy something that he
can live in I'm not saying he has to
spend all his money all I'm saying is
that we know the correlation between
home ownership and wealth building over
time I think he's going I think he's
going to get there I just think in his
single situation but I thought and his
hair is not on fire his hair is not on
fire but my my thing is like listen all
these markets are different so on Salt
Lake City if you're trying to get a
two-bedroom you know two-b condo or
townhouse and it's 400 like that's a
reality in a lot of places so do you
have the option to buy the apartment
you're in with this great
view unfortunately
no I would listen I've been to Salt Lake
there's a lot of views I bet you you
could get a house with a nice view too
or or buy a condo or buy a townhouse
with a lot listen I love ownership so
and I and I don't disagree I I just
because he's single and he's sitting on
all that cash I just would preach a
little bit of patience right now he's
been patient for seven seven long years
Ken well that was my Titanic voice by
the way I like that I like that I feel
like I see Rose and what was the guy
Jack roseen Jack yeah bobbing in the
cold icy
waters very interesting yeah you you're
not wrong to buy a house it' be a great
move for you but I also like the freedom
I go get the lady then we figure out the
house and you're stacking cash on the
way get after it young man what are you
waiting on there's a lot of fish in the
sea what are these guys waiting on these
days this is Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
all right you're listening to The ramsy
Show Ken I had to hijack the mic from
you just for a moment it's okay it's in
good hands what's going on listen a lot
of you probably remember a couple months
back really back in the summertime Ken I
kind of I kind of went nuts on the mic
because as a country our spending had
gotten completely under control out of
control you know we were looking at you
know a trillion in credit card debt for
the first time and you know inflation we
were still dealing with that and you
know I just had to let folks know listen
guys we've got to get in control of our
money and quit going on this roller
coaster and it's interesting because
really I mean over the past I'm a go
with 3 years has been crazy everything
from covid and then we saw the housing
market just
change abruptly I mean it's really been
a roller coaster you're looking at
inflation you're looking at mortgage
rates just so much change and now here
we are into the holiday season yet again
and people are still spending as though
nothing's wrong they're spending like
nothing's wrong but when you really look
at the stats is crazy I mean again here
we are over the summer it was like oh
man we hit a trillion of credit cards
debt and now we're at 1.08 trillion it's
just climbing up
1.54 billion year over year that's
unheard of unbelievable and so now we're
seeing interest rates obviously it's
more and more expensive to borrow money
so interest rates on credit cards
upwards of
20% right wow these numbers are going
just they're going mad and now we're
starting to see uh the results of our
spending choices right we all got into
house in 2021 that we couldn't afford
right everybody bought cars because
there's a shortage and it's too
expensive to buy used and everybody
bought cars they couldn't afford with
car payments $700 a month
$664 a month $882 a month maybe I called
your number there and we're finally
starting to see okay the dust is
settling a little bit the dust is
settling and we're hearing it with how
could I possibly afford to buy a house
it's the interest rates and we're
blaming the interest rates as though
they it's 1984 right and it's not it's
2023 if it was really bad we'd be seeing
18 and 16 and 17% but we're we're losing
we're losing our marbles over you know
this 3% increase or 4% increase and I'm
like is that really the problem are
mortgage rates really the issue or is it
the pattern that we've created with how
we're borrowing money and living on more
than we make it's a great question and
it comes top down if if you look at what
Congress is doing both sides of the
aisle both parties are equally guilty
the the American debt our country's debt
it's kind of the entire attitude about
debt from our leadership down is just
well we'll figure it out we'll figure it
out look at this look what they threw on
the screen right here that'll make you
break out in hives yeah that is making
me break out in hives if you're watching
uh you can see this if you're in our
listening audience James and the team
has thrown up literally a this is a
ticker board I don't know what else to
call it but is a running total of our
national debt right now that's painful
and that's 33 trillion
9915 billion dollars and it's going up
we're just watching it rise it's
crazy wow that look some of us need to
do that same exercise with our bank
account and look at it look at is your
savings going down or is it going up is
your investment going down do you even
have anything or you do know what I'm
saying you need to take a look at how
you're spending your money because like
I said we're seeing these numbers coming
in more and more people K are defaulting
on their car payments more and more
people are taking
401K loans whether it be for hardship or
for other things and the average that
they're taking out is $5,000 $5,000 that
they're robbing from their future self
to pay for what we don't know yeah have
we begun to see any pain points in the
data have you seen anything on the the
reemergence of student loans they just
started back in October so we're still
relatively we're inside of 3 months
right here listen that's another part to
this and you know we knew that it was an
issue because after student loans came
back on the scene it's like listen
people are already drowning yeah right
they're already underwater as it is and
so of course Biden Administration rolls
out that 12month on-ramp period where
they said listen if you're not ready to
pay your student loan you don't have to
right now we'll give you 12 months we're
going to continue to add interest but
you won't be penal you won't be
penalized if you won't pay it and I'm
like listen you are being penalized
that's interest Rising okay okay but the
point here is something has got to give
something has got to change in your life
because the numbers don't lie the math
is mathing whether you like it or not
we're looking at this and we're going
okay you're deeply in debt you're piling
it up and you haven't changed your ways
and just recently K the other day I did
a a media response and they said Jade
what do you think about doomsday
spending and I said well what is that
and they said it's people looking at the
current econ IC situation and going that
really sucks I'm tired of dealing with
it I'm tired of looking at it I'm just
going to live my life so it's basically
another version of like YOLO spending or
Revenge spending oh okay I thought this
was the Preppers this is different no
this is different this is people looking
and going I'm just tired of the roller
coaster I'm tired of having to cut back
because of inflation I'm tired of having
so I'm just going to forget it you know
devil make hair I'm just to spend my
money wow and I'm like really that's the
response like you run in the you you
you're gonna keep running into the fire
it's consuming you it's consuming your
future it's consuming your bank account
you can't even pay for your kids college
and you're just going to keep spending
that is not the solution no it's not
here's what I think I think it's the
beginning we're about to come into a new
year 2024 and I think that you have a
decision to make and that decision is
you can either continue to bury your
head in the sand and go this sucks I
don't like it but I'm going to keep
doing my thing I'm going to keep
spending for Christmas I'm going to keep
getting new car loans I'm going to keep
living my life because quote I deserve
it or you're going to go you know what I
don't have any
money I argue with my spouse about money
every single day yesterday I yelled at
my daughter for asking for lunch money
um gas is a struggle groceries are a
struggle I never go on vacation without
putting it on my credit card um my
daughter's going to go off to college
and she's gonna have to take out student
loans you're going to look at the
reality of your life and you're going to
go what can I change what do I need to
change and you're GNA write it down
you're going to make a list and for once
in your life you're going to make a plan
and you're going to stick to it luckily
we're here to help you with that and in
the New Year we're going to have so much
listen I talk about every dollar all the
time I talk about Financial Peace
University in the New Year this is your
chance because I I know who I'm talking
about I'm talking to the people who
circle around the ramsy network right
y'all circle around you watch the show
you come to events here and there but
you've never actually done the thing
you've never actually gotten on the plan
stuck to it gotten on a budget stuck to
your budget this is the CH this is your
chance are you going to keep taking out
credit card debt this is your chance to
cut the credit card up once and for all
and be done with it this is your choice
this is your wakeup call what we're
looking at it's it's a nightmare it's
not a dream being in debt um not living
paycheck to paycheck 67% of Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck but
they're not ready to do anything about
it yet you can make that choice that's
all I'm saying Ken people have a choice
to make well and I think you make a very
compelling case that this is an issue
whether it be money um your weight
substance issues relationship issues uh
in a job you can't stand we as humans
would rather be miserable than
uncomfortable yeah that's right and what
you've presented here is an un
believably overwhelming case that people
would rather be miserable financially
than uncomfortable meaning making the
sacrifices living on a budget not buying
a brand new car that's uncomfortable to
do things differently than you're doing
now but you're miserable and if you can
understand that I think the case that
Jade is making here is you're okay being
miserable and until you get to a point
where you go I don't want to be
miserable with money anymore I'd rather
do some things that are very
uncomfortable to not be miserable and
you and Sam did that you embraced it the
amount of money you paid off almost half
a million dollars you were uncomfortable
you have to hit that moment you the the
the stuff's got to hit the fan in your
life to where you go this is
embarrassing this is embarrassing I
remember my sister went into the
hospital and I couldn't go see her
because we didn't have the gas
money and she was just 3 hours up the
road Ken that was embarrassing and some
of you guys need to get embarrassed
about what's going going on with your
situation and go I'm I am a grown woman
I am a grown man I need to stop living
like this think about the last thing
that you needed to do and you couldn't
do it cuz you couldn't scr up
$26 that'll move you to change wow all
right we're here to help you change
quick break don't move more of your
calls coming up this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
welome welc back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me in
studio the number to jump in on the
conversation it's about your life we'd
love to hear from you triple 88255 225
5225 all right let's go to Emma who
joins us in Milwaukee Wisconsin Emma how
can we
help hi thank you both for the work that
you guys do and taking my call I really
appreciate it you bet what's going on um
yeah my my uh question today is uh about
my career um I recently have been
promoted into a new role um I love it um
my last two roles within my organization
have both been brand new roles this last
role I actually helped um promote and I
helped facilitate the job description
and what I'm actually doing for the
company today my question is is how do I
know what I'm worth in the market um
outside from this this Niche environment
and this specific organization you mean
what your salary range is outside
correct yep um well this is not a
perfect science but it's you can you can
have some good science around it so what
you have to do is is to the best of your
ability you got to match up your job
description even though you created it
custom for your current organization
which by the way I want to give you mad
props for that that's that's really
awesome that you did that that is that
is not done very often and I admire you
but uh if you could take your job
description even the language that you
use but begin to look out in the
marketplace and match that up and I
think you could probably match that up
I'll try to help you a little bit so
describe how would you describe your
current
role yeah so my current role is um
development and training um in the in a
sales department on a very basic level
that is what I do and I know there are
those roles out there um so I I do
believe that I could find um something
somewhat similar to that yeah so that's
what we're doing so we're going to look
at sales uh leadership rle sales
training roles and you just begin to
look at those job descriptions out there
and as those companies are describing
their roles how much do they match up
with what you're doing and now you're
looking at your area of Milwaukee
Wisconsin you're looking at your your
years of experience you've got it you
can't it's not it's not Apples to Apples
companies are going to look at
experience and they're going to look at
specific skill sets so if you just take
the matching up of the job description
plus your experience plus your skill set
that and you can see what the
marketplace looks like and then if you
wanted to go a step further you could
always reach out to a recruiting company
because recruiting firms are looking for
people all the time it doesn't mean
you're signing up with them doesn't mean
you're looking for a job but you go look
um you know what's the market out there
for me and that's how you can get a much
closer
idea awesome thank you very much yeah
appreciate the call all right let's go
to Lily in Indianapolis uh Lily you're
on the ramsy show what's going
on hi Ken hi thank you for answering the
call appreciate um all the advice you
give to the listeners um my question is
uh whether it's smart decision to use
cash to buy a new car uh to upgrade I
guess um from my current um car so
what's your current car worth and how
much are you trying to
upgrade right uh currently my car is
worth about 20,000 okay uh the new car
we're looking at is close to 64,000 oh
wow uh 64,000 okay what's the car yes
it's a Lexus SUV okay well let's see if
you know let's see if it makes sense do
you guys have any
debt uh we don't have any debt besides a
mortgage okay no debt besides a mortgage
do you guys have three to six months of
expenses saved
up yes we have a Ry day funds um close
to 70,000 okay excellent um we have a
sort of a set aside bucket of money to
work with uh around
48,000 okay so the 48,000 is separate
from the
70 correct okay and then what do you
guys earn what's your annual income
combined uh household wise three uh 300K
a year okay so we always say you know
you don't want um your vehicles to be
any more than half of your annual income
so and for all intents and purposes you
have $50,00 ,000 to work with here so if
you've got a vehicle that's 65,000 and
your husband's got one that's 65 or
70,000 you're good the question here is
are we is this a used vehicle or is it
brand
new it's a brand new one interesting so
then my next question is if we're
talking about doing a brand new vehicle
we always talk about um we suggest not
buying a brand new vehicle until you
have a million dollar net worth because
at that point you can take the hit right
because we know that brand new vehicles
lose 60% of their value in the first 3
to four years right what's the
model I'm sorry what's question what's
the model of the Lexus SUV is it a GX uh
it's the MX hybrid MX hybrid all right
keep going Jade I just want I love doing
research on like because I want to
because Jade's right I want to show you
the real numbers by the way is this a
2023 you want to get that the 65 2024 is
yeah the yeah they're going
and it's MX yes okay so I mean Lily do
you have a million dollar net
worth I think so we ran some numbers I
think we do um my husband would say 100%
yes I'm always on the cautious side um
what's making you feel
cautious unpack that um just my my
nature what is it like he's counting
money that you don't want to count like
what is it
like we I I have a business uh which is
doing well
um and then it just I just don't know
you know how the business will grow uh 5
10 years from now right so there's the
the unknown okay but I mean net worth
meaning when you subtract what you owe
which is nothing what you own minus what
you owe right so if you look you said I
have no debt so you're looking at the
value of your your home whatever your
home is worth and then you're looking at
what you have invested in various
Investments accounts and you're looking
at what cash you have now you could you
could include your business if you at
some point plan to sell it and you have
a valuation on that you could include
that but yeah I mean that's the question
because if you have a million dollar net
worth I'm like and you have cash to buy
a brand new car I'm not going to be the
one to stop you I'm going to
congratulate you and clap you up but if
you don't I did some homework Miss Jade
all right Ken Ken is going to tell us
the teacher Aid for this segment yes
king Coleman go for it so uh Jade is
absolutely right Lily I this is
Nashville but I would guess that that
Indianapolis maybe even a little bit
cheaper uh but but but not crazy all
right here's what I've got I've got a
used
2022 um the
NX 19,000 miles for 419 whoa I got a
that's 24 that's $23,000 difference yeah
I'm going to do better I got a I used
2022 same model uh 21,000 Mi only 2,000
Mi difference
379 oh I'm just saying 19,000 miles is
is new that's a new car and here's what
we're saying Lily we just want your
money to go further like this isn't
going to break you but paying 65,000 for
this model for a 2024 you realize you're
getting ripped off because these cars
this is a 2-year-old car not even
2-year-old car I'm giving you right here
that's right and and saving a lot of
money so I like the $41,000 I want her
to feel bad if she has if she got the
million dollar net worth I want her to
inhale that new car smell until her
eyeballs roll in the back of her head
you know what I'm saying like I want her
to enjoy that moment if you've got that
million dollar net worth cuz then you
can take the hit and you know it is what
it is not me I feel like I'm getting
ripped off I'm getting gamed well you
are you you're agreeing to take the hit
you're right you're I'd like someone
else to take the hit see and here's the
thing with these two cars here uh Lily
we've someone else has has paid the
stupid tax I'm just trying to make my
case here and listen yeah it doesn't
matter if I'm right I'm just saving you
money you can't hate me Lily yes so Lily
let's go back to the core people let's
go back to the core question cuz my
screen says is it smart for me to buy a
$65,000 car or should I invest some of
that money as long as you are investing
15% of your income every single month as
long as you have a million dollar net
worth and as long as you can pay cash
for that brand new car for
me the answer is yes for that reason I
agree I'm in you can do it you're big
girl Lily we we believe in you but if
one of those things doesn't check the
box then we have to adjust yeah and if
you don't want to pay a stupid tax go
Ken's route I like it Ken that's good
got to get the last word in there I
can't help myself really good stuff hey
Lily you're awesome you're doing great
enjoy whatever car you're going to get
this is the ramsy show
[Music]
w
the Ramsey Show continues thrilled to
have you with us we're here to help you
win with your money and your work today
I'm K Colman Jade warshaw joins me and
oh it is the season T the season Jade
and uh you know Christmas around here is
is always really fun as we get to uh do
some great things for you you folks uh
part of our audience so we get two
things one uh it's not too late to get
involved in the ramsy Christmas Cash
giveaway if you don't know what this is
um one of our weekly prizes each week is
$500 and then you're entered to win the
grand prize of $5,000 so you can enter
every day for your chance of winning at
ramsy solutions.com
giveaway and while you're on the website
over in the store we've got our $12 sale
uh the Christmas special all of our
bestselling books just $12 each uh and
there's a meaningful gift for just about
anybody on your list so that's Ramy
solutions.com store ramsy solution.com
giveaway make sure that you are signing
up for a chance to win 500 bucks and
maybe even $5,000 so uh get to the
website I don't know what you're waiting
on all right let's go to fville Arkansas
next Elizabeth joins us there Elizabeth
how can we
help hey thank you for having me on you
bet what's up so I'm not sure what I
should do um there's kind of two sides
to um what's going on I guess um so do
you want to hear the maral side part or
the financial side part first let's hear
the marital side per first okay okay so
I'm going to start kind of back to a
year ago um so I left I left my
ex-husband which was financially
abusive um and I got out and since then
it's been kind of
a I've been keep getting thrown back
down I guess is what it would be um do
you mind telling us briefly what
financially financially abusive
means um yeah I had a budget of $50 a
week for groceries for my family and
that's the only access of money I had
wow who so it totally controlled you
totally controlling wow what was you
guys'
income um he made about 70,000 a year
and wow um I read Dave Ramsey's books
about four years ago and I got so pumped
and I I brought it up to him and he just
despised
Dave and it kind of shut me down a lot
and he wouldn't let me in on anything
like I even wrote out like a strategy
for him like Hey like if we do this and
this this is what we're going to be
projecting right to getting out of debt
because at the moment like we had I
think a car debt
and uh some other a couple other things
credit cards probably eventually we did
get out of it luckily um so now I'm back
in debt tell us what you yeah okay so
tell us what's happening you said you
keep going down so give us a picture of
what's going on with you right now the
finances so I I scored a job right after
I left him in December or and I started
in January of last year okay and I was
there till about April okay and between
then and like April my idea was I have
six months I'm going to save up enough
for a retainer for a liyar and I guess
um do it myself like file and everything
on my own for C like cash but he beat me
to it about 30 days later I got served
and I had to take out a credit card for
a retainer because I had zero
money um and I had I got a an apartment
within like I don't know January 10th is
when I got my apartment okay and I
pretty much got everything set up on my
own by myself and I don't know how I did
it but I did it and
it's just been back and forth I got let
go I was pregnant at the time when I did
leave so I
was yeah I was about 13 weeks pregnant I
think if I can remember correctly um and
I got let go in April for budget cuts I
guess
and so how are you how are you living
now how are you making inss meet you've
got the baby now you've got your place
what's how are you covering the yeah um
I have child support but it's really
like if he it's not set amount and I
have that and then how much is that I
was able it's supposed to be 700 a
month but it's not you you can't count
on it yet is what you're saying not
quite cuz I looked back in some months I
had like 400 and some months I had um
600 okay so he's not consistent with
that what are you bringing in every
month well I
after I had the baby I got on a contract
um contract gig for about 200 a week and
I paired that and the 200 and then at
the time I 800 for
you yes at the time I had a boyfriend
and when I got let go I told him I was
like I don't know what to do I can't I
can't like I'm not going to be able to
my house you were needing him to help
you support you were needing the
boyfriend to help support obviously cuz
you were bringing in 800 okay what kind
of work do you do choice so I'm a I'm in
the marketing industry so I'm a social
media manager um so I did DM stuff for a
fitness coach and then now I found a job
after I got let go of that one the
contract ran out and I found another one
at an agency but it's only for 60 days
and it's going up at the end of this
month okay and I have an option to
become an employee depending on how I do
that makes sense I'm going to can get to
you with the with the career stuff
because I I need you to be doing more
that's earning you five times more money
and I know that you can do that he's
going to help you get there um before I
set him up do you un the what I want you
to see is you can't two people can't
live off of $800 a
month and even if you're even if the
child support becomes consistent you
can't live off of $1,300 a month or
$1,500 a month okay so the income I'm
actually getting about 1,200 with this
new job okay currently but you still
need more because that's $2,000 a month
and $2,000 a month is $24,000 a
year yes so do we see so a little I have
to drop the bomb on this one okay after
the everything got um finalized I kind
of my ex came up to me
and I don't know what his intention was
but essentially he knew that my
boyfriend was living with me and he told
me I'm basically in contempt and I have
to figure out what to do or he'll file
for contempt and so what's the contempt
I talk to my um basically cohab
cohabitating with another male while you
have the
baby and my six-year-old yes well yeah
okay yes he can do that because if the
if the tables look I'm not trying to be
harsh but if the tables were turned
you'd be feeling the same way so what I
want for let me let me paint a picture
of what I want for you and I'm just
going to be blunt I want a situation
where you're not dependent on a man
period yeah because right now do you
understand because they can come and go
and you're bringing these guy you don't
want to be bringing these guys into your
kids life in and out right and you have
you're fresh off of a divorce and it's
almost like I'm just telling you what it
sounds like from my seat it almost
sounds like you just rushed into another
relationship because you needed
stability you your stability doesn't
come from them okay you need to go out
and create the stability in your own
life and you need to get your community
rallied around you good friends family
if you're not connected in a local
church I don't care what you believe in
get connected in a local church because
those people are not going to care what
you believe they're going to Rally
around you they're going to love you
you're going to be a good friend to them
they're going to be a good friend to you
you need you need people not not just
boyfriends does that make
sense yeah but my lawyer told me to um
so the judge is known for like revoking
children for reason so my lawyer told me
to either move him out or marry him and
so we had to do that so did you get
married yeah we did but we were planning
on it um anyways and I talked to my
therapist about it too like Okay so now
you're married I wrote it out for him
yes okay so now you're married so the
contempt thing doesn't matter you told
it to me like it matters it don't matter
anymore all right come on Ken it doesn't
know yeah yeah it doesn't know we got a
lot going on here James
uh and we're running out of time uh I
rarely do this we usually don't hold
over for the hour but what we want to
get her a financial coach so hang on the
line uh you need a financial coach but
listen to me now that you're married to
this guy which would have been nice to
know 5 minutes ago okay he has got to to
be working 50 60 hours a week you have
got to get some help with the babies and
you're working 40 hours a week this is
an income issue and you've got to get
more of it and you got to keep more of
it we're going to get you Financial
coaches our gift to you to help you get
a budget and get set up you better go
get some work fast both of you this is
the Ramy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
w
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help you win in your life in your
money in your work and in your
relationships 88255 225 is the number
for you to call in we're here for you
I'm Ken Coleman Jake warshaw joins me
5225 all right up first going back to my
stomping grounds okay the 757 folks LOVE
Hampton Roads Beach area is where Raven
joins us Raven how can we
help hello hi thank you for taking my
call you bet what's going on Raven all
right so I've been on our debt free
Journey since December 22 uh 2022 uh we
started with about 70k in debt now we
have 41,000 in debt which includes a
$38,000 car and $3,000 in student loans
however we are outgrowing our house um
so we started looking at houses is just
to just to prepare to look for the
future we found a great location that's
about 30 minutes closer to my husband's
job and next thing you know we picked a
lot and put the earnest money down next
thing you know look at that just
happened you guys had no control over
that isn't that crazy
none girl okay it so I know there's a
butt or there's a problem somewhere so
tell me a butt tell me what happened
immediately immediately we started
crunching the numbers cuz I'm the one
that got started on this journey and
found uh Dave um but as of today we owe
um 155,000 on our current home okay um
we could sell it for at least 330,000
which would be a profit of about 160k
after paying the realtor okay and we
have 50k in
savings um so the new home cost 70 or
$700,000 uh we're building a new house
yeah we're building a new house so it
won't be ready till July where um and by
time what area um Greenbrier Hickory
area I know that area chesap yeah you
upgraded you upgraded didn't you big
time yes we're very excited great
schools great location everything so
you're still in the current house you
haven't sold it but when you do you'll
take 160k from that right in equity yeah
and then you're going to put that with
150 so that's you know 300 a little over
300 and you're going to take that to put
on this new property which is a $700,000
property did I get that right um almost
so we uh so we owe 150 on the current
home so and and if we sell it for 320 we
would profit 160 plus the 50k so 50 okay
I thought they're really only going to
have about 210 is what you would have
correct yes sorry yes so you're putting
210 down on a house that costs 700,000
uh just about so we figured we would use
um some of that to finish paying off the
car um and to you know obviously put
down 20% for the down payment save three
uh months of expenses of expenses which
is about 20 to 25 with the new house
mortgage um and I think we should be
free and clear but I just wanted to get
you guys' input to change I'm G get out
I'm GNA get out my calculator real quick
why you do that okay are you in a
contract I mean this is you can't get
out of this or do you do we have any
wigg I mean we probably yeah we probably
could but I'm sure we would lose some
money so what did you specifically call
us for what do you want Jade to weigh in
on here what what's going on uh just to
So the plan was to pay off the car the
student loan before we bought a house
but you know uh we did that a little
early so I just want wanted to get some
reassurance that we're we're still kind
of on the right track okay so if we look
at the numbers okay so you've got the
210,000 and you want to pay off the
41,000 in debt with that right so that
leaves you with
169,000 okay well if we pay pay it off
then it would be around July so by then
we would probably only owe about 38 or
or I'm sorry okay so $3,000 L by then oh
okay so $10,000 difference okay so then
let's say that leaves you with
179,000 fair enough okay and then you
want to take out how much for your three
to six months
25,000 yes about 20 to 25 let's say
25,000 because you're going to be a new
homeowner okay so that drops you back
down what you need you need to be
putting you said you want to put 20,000
down on this house so what is that about
140,000 that you need to put
down yes okay so that puts you I mean
you're right up against it but that puts
you right there
um yeah I mean what's what's the
question what what's your concern are
you worried that you what are you
worried
about because there's a sense of worry
there yeah because I you know I think
we'll be okay we've got a couple of
raises coming in and
um uh come starting the new year we
don't really know exactly how much that
would be but that would be about um
maybe a thousand more a mon after it
here here's a deal what what she's
worried about I I'm sensing your worry
your worry is not what what you're going
to do with this equity and paying off
the debt what you're worried about is
the percentage of your monthly income
that this mortgage is going to be so
that's what we need to be talking about
abely what's the mortgage going to be
what's the mortgage G to be uh looking
about 48 depending on the interest rate
4800 a
month yes okay and how much do you bring
home every single month after taxes
not after investing and everything like
that just after
taxes after taxes I bring home 28 my
husband brings home about
64 that's before our raises that are
coming up January okay so you're
bringing home $9,200 a month and you're
basically at
half that's too much that's why you're
that's why you're feeling crazy this has
nothing to do with you selling the house
and paying off the debt and da D D D D
what you're worried about is you're you
guys are buying a house that's going to
be 50% of your take-home pay every month
and you I'm just letting you know you're
going to feel that and even adding
$1,000 to it that helps but you need to
be getting this thing down to
25% and y'all got to do it fast because
nothing will make a blessing feel like a
burden quicker than not being able to
afford it and I would absolutely hate
that for you guys
okay so really I think what this call is
about Ken let's turn a corner how can
they get their income up well I actually
I I don't know I I I don't know their
situation we got about a minute here so
what do you what What professions are
you guys in give me the really quick
answer um I'm in Contracting with the
government and my husband is just got
promoted to Master Chief in the Navy
yeah so you guys are your your incomes
in those things are limited
so now you're talking about side hustles
and I don't think the side hustles is
going to make the difference I think
there's too much house and I'd walk away
from the
house that's that's the truth you guys
are both in government jobs so the only
way you're making extra money is going
to be and you have limited time and
that's not going to make up the
difference Jade to get enough income in
to get it to the 25% so I hate to tell
you this but it's too much house yeah I
I wish I had another answer it's but
going and making more money is not the
answer to this you guys are going to be
house poor new house means new furniture
new problems decorating all the things
you could put more down on the house and
just pay off your debt the oldfashioned
way that's your only other option later
but even then I don't know if it makes
that much of a difference so I mean run
those numbers I mean she gave you the
ratio so um I'd be patient this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman J warshaw joins me we're taking
your questions about your money about
your work professional advancement means
financial advancement can I do that
while I'm in the baby steps want to
start that side hustle this next year
we'll take any of those questions 8825
5225 tri8 825
5225 Marissa is up in Houston Texas
Marissa how can we
help yes hi um thank you so much for
taking my call and um uh first I guess I
just needed some advice on what to do um
I currently I'm 30 years old and I'm
thinking of changing my career I'm going
back to school to what uh you know uh to
nursing and what are you doing now I'm a
pharmacy Tri okay yeah all right keep um
so uh so yeah so I'm trying thinking of
going back to school um but I'm kind of
um stuck in between picking um an the
celerator program which will cost me
about
70,000 or for hold on I'm sorry did you
say 70 or
seven 70 s
$70,000 yes for what um for uh
bachelor's and nursing okay gotcha it's
a onee program so I think that's why
it's so much wow so I'm in between yeah
but uh so going for that program or
going to on to a associates degree in
nursing which will be a two years and
that comes out to be about 10K
uh but I would still have to go back to
school uh another year uh that's
probably about another 30,000 for a
bachelor's that's a big difference okay
so if I'm hearing you right 10,000 for
the associates then another did you say
30 about it could range from 15 to 30k
15 to 30 for the yeah um depending on
what program I get accepted to for The
Bachelors uh having my associates I
could um you know do one I could get a
into a bachelor's um nursing program uh
and that will be another year so total
will be like three years for the longer
rout can I ask a quick question so the
15 to 30,000 for The Bachelors what
denotes that can you just apply to
programs that are cheaper or like no so
okay so the um let's see the associates
um uh you know you have to take certain
um credit classes that's basically all
the requirements you have to take
certain classes yeah and then uh for the
one year um the 30k you have to have an
associate priority in nursing right but
you said the range was between 15 and 30
15 and 30k and I was trying to
understand what denotes that range
depending on school some schools are
cheaper than others um but I've looked
around and um depending on who accepts
um you know um accepts me it can be from
the cheapest I've looked it's 15,000 and
so you'll just apply to the cheapest
ones right right right always because
Marissa no patient will ever ask you how
much you paid to go to nursing school
yeah we're not even applying for the 32
on so don't even think about that so so
you've laid this out for us the $70,000
bachelor's one-year program to me makes
no sense at all because I'm guessing you
cannot afford anything close to that is
that
true right yeah what can you afford
right now how much money do you have to
be able to put towards
school um So currently I have about 14k
cash do you have any
debt no no debt well like small credit
card debt like 2,000 may but that's debt
sweetheart Marissa that's debt well yeah
s right but I can pay it off like it
doesn't have any it's not accumulating
any interest it doesn't matter it's
still debt what other debt do you have
okay uh that's about it really I don't
have any loans because car payment no
car no car payments no all right so you
only have debt of $2,000 on a credit
card and you have $144,000 in savings or
or is that in your checking that's in my
checking any
savings uh well that's that's all I have
so I got her her savings is in her
checking account well here's the deal I
I certainly would cash flow the the
two-year Associates program because my
question is is once you get that
associate are you able to do any kind of
nursing at all or
no yeah I can um I believe once I get
into the program or once I receive my
associates I can work in a hospital for
about year uh within that year they they
do require you to get your Bachelor so
so I be working how much money are you
making right now as a pharmacy
tech uh right now um net pay is about
40K and grow is about 55 all right any
opportunity for
overtime um not well yes I take it as um
as much as I can I also work part-time
at uh for right now my my full-time job
is at the hospital and and I work
part-time at like a retail pharmacy okay
so what are you bringing in total so
full-time plus parttime is it the 55 or
is it more than that don't know maybe
about 60 okay because I work like yeah
on the weekends well um but another
thing too is um was like I said I'm 30
I'm not married I don't have any kids
but like I'm my partner right now um we
we want to kind of settle down and he's
not forcing me to go to school he says
like I guess combined we would be good
but I guess the nursing school is just
for me um to be uh to increase my my
income um but my question is should I
well I guess like y'all said I should
just go ahead and do the the associates
degree no go ahead ask your question
it'll take longer well it's just because
I I guess in the next three or four
years it would like to like have kids
and buy a house and all of that uh so I
guess that's fing between those two pro
like like if I should do the the the
faster route pay a little bit more you
can't afford the faster route can't yeah
that's got to be off the table because
you don't have $7,000 you don't even
make that in a in a year and I don't say
that to be negative I'm just saying you
need $70,000 in one year and you make 60
and if you do that and you take a loan
out for that Marissa guess what it's
going to put everything else you dream
of that you just mentioned the home the
kids it puts all that in Jeopardy this
is not necessary I I I with the income
you have
the fact that you are single uh you've
got some extra time the boyfriend's
supportive I mean I I would cash flow
the 10K for the two-year program get you
in the building I wrote an entire book
called The Proximity principle which
says I got to get around people that
doing what I want to do and if that gets
you in and I cash flow and I'm in
nursing um then the angle I'm going for
Marissa is I'm looking for a hospital or
a program or a clinic or something says
I'm willing to pay a good chunk of
Marissa's tuition and let me just add
this is just what all I'm saying I'm not
saying this is the case but there is
something to be said for a lot of people
think how many times do people call in
and say I got a whole degree in this
field I started working and I hate it
well that's another thing that's a very
good point have you hung out with nurses
so when she does that $10,000 she's
going to be able to hang out with these
people and see does she really like it I
I agree with you so much I wouldn't I
wouldn't spend the 10,000 until you
spend time with nurses have you spent
time with nurses like really ask the
good the bad the
ugly yeah I mean I know what the work is
um my best friend's a nurse she's been a
nurse for five years um so I know what
it is I I know nurses too um it's tough
and it's tough it is tough and I say
that specifically because nursing is one
of those fields that it's like you've
got to be wired for this so shelling out
$70,000 a year and speeding through a
program getting into it and being like
oh wait this is for the birds you'll
feel terrible at least with the T the
10e you know the uh two-year plan
getting the associates and then doing
the year bachelor's she gets to test it
but I I hear you can testing it before
them would be good too well I think she
has I think you meet that you know what
it is and you know what you want to do
so so we are saying you're going to
you're going to you're going to walk
through this not run and we're going to
walk through at the speed of cash cash
cash cash you're going to be in you're
going to be a nurse I really want you
shaking the tree talking to everybody
about what kind of program
you know will the hospitals listen
there's a huge need for nurses right now
I talk about this every day I want you
to see what's out there as it relates to
somebody paying your tuition because
they need new Talent they need new
people in the building and you represent
that so no debt on this no loan it's not
worth it and it's not needed it'd be one
thing if it were like there's no other
way trust me there's always another way
besides taking out a loan so really
appreciate the call Marissa you don't
understand how big of a deal it is to be
a new nursing candidate they are they
are hemorrhaging people they need people
you might be surprised Jade how many
hospitals organizations will say you
know what we'll help you with your
tuition and that way you have no debt
and you jump right in so thanks for the
call all right don't go anywhere more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
welcome back America you have joined the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman and Jade
warshaw joins me and Jade's a little
fired up as we went into our commercial
break she had about 30 seconds more that
she said she needed to add listen
um if you call in the show you need to
know how much money you
make that listen or she will hang up
with I think just in life not if you
call on the show as a person in life
that's right James in life you need to
know how much money you make we talk
about budgeting we talk about FPU we
talk about the baby steps the number one
thing you cannot do any of that if you
don't know how much money you make and I
mean to the penny you need to know every
time when I get a check this is the
amount now if you're self-employed or
you have a fluctuating income it's a
little different but you need to have a
a clear picture of what you think it
probably will be based on you know what
you've been doing but you need to know
how much you make guys I say it all the
time your income is expensive okay the
money you make is expensive Jade what do
you mean by that I mean you spend your
time you spend your energy you spend
your sleep some of you spend your sanity
your income is expensive it costs you
all right handle it with care understand
what it actually is so that you can make
it work for you that's it your homework
for tonight is to look at your payub and
memorize it all right that's it I can
hear the a I can hear the audience in my
head yes Miss Jade yes Mama J couple
things here real quick um coming off of
that mini rant uh my colleague here look
at that look at her she looks like a
million dollars right look nice right
there money's not a math problem like a
nice person uh a fun little short book
here that she has written the real
reason you're broke and what to do about
it really really good stuff this is now
is it available actually now where where
pre-order is is gone it's now go get it
today listen if you order it from Ramsey
solutions.com we will send it right to
you if you order it on Amazon a you're
paying more money for it and you have to
wait till January 2nd to get it so go to
ramsy solutions.com and get it get the
book it's really great by the way you
music lovers will love that her chapters
are titled they're all song I just
picked up on that did you just get that
okay I love it do you recognize the
songs yeah absolutely are you kidding me
hey now you're an Allstar don't make me
sing it my favorite is chapter 4 sled
Hammer oh we harmonized there wow that
was incredible not rehearse that it was
great she's very talented uh and then
speaking of uh fun books for the family
I'm glad for what I have Rachel Cruz is
first where's our camera sorry guys I
feel like David Letterman used to do
this all the time I was growing up there
it is I'm glad for what I have Rachel
Cruz's children's book it's all about
contentment and then our good buddy
George camel we got another money book
out here look at George Breaking Free
from broke great book all of those books
Ramy solutions.com store these are great
gifts for
you to give yourself and to others so go
get them at ramsy
solutions.com
store all right to Los Angeles we go
Amelia is there Amelia how can we
help hi there um I just wanted to ask
today about budgeting thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's going on
um I used to live in an area with really
low cost of living and so since moving
out here um I'm just finding that it's
really hard to kind of save and put
money into an emergency fund I feel like
on months where there's no emergencies
and where we make the amount of money
we're expecting to make that we do great
on our budget and then um I feel like
half of the months were just barely kind
of scraping by and having to pull out of
that emergency fund so um I would just
love some advice on how to kind of
budget in an area where it's a really
high cost of living yeah I mean on the
one hand I'm just going to say budgeting
is budgeting whether you're in a low
cost of living or High Cost of Living
the whole point of a budget is you're
you're simply planning your money before
the month begins so kind of take the
high if if if the cost of living is an
issue that means you have an income
issue not necessarily A budgeting issue
so let's start with that framework so so
how much money do you guys make per
month um total me and my husband end up
bringing in like 7,500 a month okay good
and then um he's a student so he also
gets just random payouts for
scholarships okay so I would say like
three times a year we get like 5,000
about 5,000 and is that just refunds
from the scholarship money you know it's
just a little different each time so the
school that he's at he he has a TAA ship
and so he gets paid like a monthly fee
or not like whatever salary for nine
months of the year okay and then he has
some scholarships that are set and then
some that the school it's almost like
surprise scholarships and I don't really
know why there's a letter he signed at
the beginning of the year but we always
end up getting a little more than what's
on the letter we don't really know where
it's coming from okay but does the money
go into your budget or does it need to
be going to toward School um that is on
top of what we pay for the school so the
5,000 is what we get after paying okay
so it's just a credit back to you okay
and how often did you say every quarter
every couple months that's right every I
would say three times a year so three
times a year and it's anywhere between 3
to 5,000 so let's just keep that on hold
in our minds right now um I'm not going
to add it to the budget just yet okay so
7,500 a month so if you haven't
downloaded every which is our budgeting
app here that's your homework for
getting off the phone today do you
already have it or no um I have the yeah
I have the free version okay I want you
to go to ramsy solutions.com and I want
you to buy the book money's not a math
problem it's $10 but when you buy it for
$10 you will get three months of every
dollar premium for free so that's kind
of a backd door way to get every dollar
premium for free for a lot cheaper okay
that's the homework because on premium
this is what you need premium features
has something called paycheck planning
so basically what you do when you first
do your budget right you just go through
and you assign every single dollar right
until it says you've got an every dollar
budget in green right okay so that's
what you do first you're just assigning
every single dollar and once you've
assigned every dollar with a category
like this is for gas this is for the
mortgage this is for groceries it wants
you to use every single dollar and when
you've used every dollar it'll say up
there in green you've done an every
dollar budget woohoo now that's step one
and a lot of people stop right there and
they're like all right I did my budget
winning and then they Wonder oh my gosh
why am I still overdrawing oh my gosh
why do I still not have any money it's
because they've left out a very crucial
step and I want everybody listening to
remember this you have got to plan your
paychecks some people call it cash flow
planning and in every dollar premium it
allows you to do that and all that is uh
Amelia is you're going in there and
you're saying okay I've given every
dollar an assignment I've told my money
what to do now I have to tell it when to
do it I've got to set the dates because
here's the thing you don't necessarily
you might get paid on the first but you
don't know do I have the money to pay
the rent the mortgage the car payment D
if you don't know you have to plan it
out otherwise you are going to be
overdrawing even though you've made a
budget does that make sense yeah okay
can I jump into a quick question Amilia
I'm curious are you guys double
income um so yes for Nine Months of the
Year it's um he's making about 4,000 I'm
making anywhere from 33500 to 4,000 what
industry are you guys in um I'm a
teacher and then he's a TA at a
university right now the reason I'm
asking this is I'm just curious what
does upward Mobility look like for you
guys financially over the next 24 months
so think two years yeah well to be
honest the next step that we're kind of
hoping to take um he is about to grab
uate so we have about 6 months of our
current situation where we are trying to
kind of save while we're making more
money so that when we move to a new
location we can kind of have that
emergency fund and then have our down
payment for a house same area though Los
Angeles we're moving away yeah okay but
here's here's my question though I
appreciate that but would Jade gave you
great budgeting advice but I'm just
curious what what the income increase
potential looks like over the next two
years cuz I've got a suggestion but I'm
curious what that are you guys going to
see some raises or are they minimal I
got about 40 seconds tell me real quick
minimal to pay decreases
probably yeah I I had a feeling and so
you know I could say you guys need to be
making some side hustle income but the
point is is then you're just you never
are you're rat in a wheel so I just feel
like we got to make better decisions
where we live man what can I just say
that yes k I I I'm not by the way
everything Jade said is spot on and you
can win with what and and you guys have
had months where you should be winning
with good budget so she'll help you but
I also got to go it shouldn't be that
difficult maybe we should teach
somewhere else that's right just a
thought this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number Isle 8825 5225 our scripture of
the day comes from Proverbs 8 1815 an
intelligent heart acquires knowledge and
the ear of the wise seeks knowledge our
quote from Abraham Lincoln I do not
think much of a man who is not wiser
today than he was yesterday all right
shots fired Abe dropping the wisdom of
course there was so many quotes out
there from Abraham Lincoln yeah by the
way hold on you just said shots fired he
was salty in that
quote too soon too soon too soon he died
by an assassin in for that's what I was
just he just went pardon the pun yeah he
got shot in the back of the head Jade
listen I was about to say he was giving
someone the smoke on that but that's
probably to the same thing I love that
you went shots fired it took me a second
it was like a delayed reaction for me
too it wasn't on purpose we apologize
Abe moment of silence okay that's all
right to John we go in Detroit Michigan
John how can we help how's it going so
the company that I work for is uh a
union company and I a part of the Union
as an employee we're negotiating our
contract right now and then things
aren't going great so there's the
possibility that we may be going on
strike yeah I'm on baby step two and I I
know based on what I've heard from you
guys that maybe I should pause the baby
steps and start saving cash for the
possibility that I can't work but I kind
of don't want to do that I want to keep
the the snow snowball
rolling which tells me you've thought
through this so is there any kind of a
stien I know I I'm I'm not super
familiar on unions but I know that many
unions will have a fund for these type
of Labor negotiations and so my question
is do you do you have that what would
that be financially how much of the of
um of that uh I'm struggling how much of
a percentage of that would it be your
normal pay is that a pay cut walk us
through that yeah it's a huge pay cut
it'd be a very small amount of money
just a few hundred a week you know for
gas and groceries so when you said I
don't want to pause the baby steps I
want to keep going do you have a plan
sounds like you do yeah so what I was
thinking was I was going to bump my
credit card up from its current position
and pay on that and then if worst case
scenario I do go on strike I would have
the liquid funds in the credit card if
I know
what really think keep paying no way no
way John okay you're playing games let's
let's talk about what we really could do
cuz I I feel I feel what you're thinking
like I'm not going to lie I get what
you're thinking and like on some scale
somewhere else it makes sense but on the
Ramsay scale it's bananas so let's pull
it back my question for you would be of
course I get it like you want to keep
the baby step you know baby step to
snowball rolling you don't want to lose
momentum if you do go on strike are you
allowed to work another job or do you
can you not do anything I could yeah I
could work another job I would not get
that stien pay unless
I'm how much do you make what's your
take home our household income is around
58,000 what your 35 35 36 of that is
mine and that's what I budget I Budget
on the low end we're kind of on the
irregular income side I'm cont track to
make 120 this year in the household and
what kind of work do you do that you
would be possibly going on strike
for uh it's manufacturing and
distribution okay my what I would do if
I were you is I would start researching
other jobs that I could pivot to to make
up I mean to make $36,000 a year three
grand a month yeah that's three I mean
you could you could get a you could
literally get a management position at
Chick-fil-A and make that well I I agree
with Jade here I think your play here is
to get aggressive do you have an idea of
the timeline as to win this strike would
happen no I'm not certain we're not
meeting with the company again for
another month yeah I without saying
anything I pay attention to stuff every
day I know what you're talking about so
this thing could the can could get
kicked down the road even a little
further that it's going to be a month
before they even start talking again so
I think you have I think realistically
John tell me if I'm wrong I don't mind
being wrong that you've got about 90
days at least before for anything were
to happen in this scenario is that
fair yeah y that's why that's why I
don't want to pause the baby step nobody
telling you to we're not talking about
positive baby steps we're talking about
what do we do financially so that you
can keep going in the midst of this
strike because I think that's the issue
you could keep going the baby steps if
we have an income plan so I think
there's two things to look at I'm pivot
quickly from this I would be asking
myself if I were in your shoes how can I
make three grand a month using my skill
and experience
in the Detroit area so that I can start
doing that now and I'm stacking that up
the second question I would be asking is
since sounds like you budget really well
could you make it through a two or three
month strike on your wife's income only
what's the answer to that no all right
then so now we know we got to focus on
step one yeah yeah I think it's all
about having a a income plan but if he
doesn't should should he pause the baby
steps I think he should but why wouldn't
he that's my thing like I don't think
that not working for two months is an
option I agree or three months is an
option I agree but I'm saying what I'm
doing is I'm giving a full look at this
thing so if he can't find the work I
mean and he goes on strike then then we
would tell him to do that I'm just
saying fundamentally when we tell people
to pause baby steps is a true emergency
situation where you've got to just take
care of business I mean he's I don't
think he's going to have to rely you
said he's got 90 days so I think so I
would say that if if we're to months in
and there's still not a a plan of like
what you're going to Pivot to then maybe
stop and pile up some cash but I don't
want that to be an excuse I don't want
there to be any excuses to not find this
income does that make sense I don't want
you moving the credit card in your
babysit in your you know in your debt
snowball don't do that because that is
going to attempt that's going to tempt
you you've already been tempted to have
that as your fallback plan and I just
want you to erase that you need to pull
a straight up like men in black and just
clear that from your memory of ever
thinking I like that reference of ever
thinking you know what I'm saying I
don't even want you thinking that the
credit card could possibly be an option
John do you know what I'm saying yeah my
only thought was that would be a liquid
place that I could continue to pile
money think about what you're saying you
got to stop saying liquid think about
what you're saying yeah you're so in
think think about this now you're so
intent on wanting to keep moving forward
in your Deb snowball
if you're wanting to go forward you
cannot solve a problem while
simultaneously creating it you can't get
out of debt while still having debt as
an option to lean back on you'll never
go forward so keep the intensity on
wanting to keep the debt snowball going
and the only way to do that is to say
debt is not an option and let me tell
you something John when you do that you
will get so creative and you will start
having ideas come out of the Wazoo
because you don't have a choice
necessity is the mother of invention and
so when you that's why I said am I that
that thought because when you do that
okay I have no choice I have to provide
for my family you will go out because I
can tell you're a hard worker you will
go out and do whatever it takes to bring
money in for your family when you take
de debt off the table John what is your
skill
set uh equipment uh service I'm a
service technician so mechanical work
yeah yep my man I'm asking you straight
up is there not a lot of stuff that
needs fixing that you can fix in the
Greater Detroit area
yeah there is it's just finding who
wants me to go fix it John everybody
sounds like there's some really nice
money to be made and what if John what
if we start today tonight contacting
people putting the word out what if John
you make an additional three grand a
month over the next three months and the
strike doesn't happen
wo I like it John are you with me I am
yeah you remember the old phrase you
sound like a guy who's like understands
all these old phrases that they all make
fun of me for saying on the show
remember the old take the bull by the
horns you know that phrase yeah yep come
on John grab that bull by the horns and
wrestle it to the ground get after it
this Strike should not be a blip on your
radar screen if you approach it that way
do you do you agree with me hopefully it
never happens hopefully it never happens
who cares if it does we got a plan Jade
and I just came up with a plan that
doesn't matter if it happens or not
we're really excited about it well I'm
fired up let me tell you why I'm fired
up because most of these strikes never
last very long at all it's too expensive
yeah so they'll happen but they don't go
very long and if he has a plan for this
he ends up coming out on the positive
side with cash true which means we dump
all of that right into the baby steps
and we move on John thanks for the call
Jade warshaw thank you great show thanks
for harmonizing with me I got to call my
mom she's going to be so proud James
child's our fearless leader thank you
sir this is the r
[Music]
show